the Joe Rogan experience you know
towards the end of my career like I just
didn't I didn't finish the way I wanted
to you know and I felt like you know
after I came back from my injuries I
just wasn't the same for our fighter
anymore I just were you not the same
physically or was it mentally it was
physical but it also it became mental
because it was because physically I just
didn't feel the same you know I didn't
feel like I ever regained the power back
in my legs and for the most part my legs
were everything you know the injuries I
had to ACL surgeries on my mama right
knee and that completely just uh
it changed everything for me because you
know being a smaller light heavyweight
all of my power was all in my legs you
know and whatever couldn't make up for
in the size department up top I was
usually able to make up for with the
power of my legs you know is that
related to the injury that you got when
you were at Jacksons and Diego Sanchez
crashed into you know that was so that
was a different injury so that was a MCL
but it wasn't my left knee so the right
knee wasn't that you know I always drove
me crazy because I'm like why the [ __ ]
is a guy training for a world title
fight or in a regular class where
everybody knows people collide in the
people at regular classes all the time
with millions of dollars on the line I
know I see that all the time though in
top gyms and but that see that stuff
that's that's where that the training
has gone like like before we would train
like maniacs we would try and crazy as
hell and put ourself in some crazy
situations and you and you try to put
yourself in a situation because you like
you know I did it before and I've done
it so many times and nothing has
happened but when you start to move up
and there's more on the line then you
always have to take every single
precaution because you can't afford to
take a step back right and for me once I
have my knee injuries though I just
mentally was not the same person and
when I competed I wasn't the same person
and then it affected me because then I'm
like you know I'm not the same person
did you lose the ability to explode with
your knees did you have meniscus damage
as well um I had meniscus damage I lost
the ability to explode and I lost it
would get tired my leg I get tired you
know and it didn't have the same bounce
the same rhythm and he kinda felt kind
of felt heavy and I couldn't really feel
it
in the front you know the front part of
my knee I couldn't really feel it I had
a little did you have a patellar tendon
graft I had a patellar tendon so they
cut the front open and then they take
the piece of the bone they take a slice
of the patellar tendon a piece of the
bone on the bottom and they replace your
ACL with that correct yeah I did that
too it takes a long time to get that
feeling back yeah it took me more than a
year before it felt right and then even
then if I was on my knees it would hurt
like hell
see that's the thing like I still to
this day like I still have dead spots
where I can't feel in my knee
well it's numb yes you know and I think
I had to do it a lot because I had to of
the knee surgeries back to back like
when I was only healing up for my first
one then it ruptured again so then I go
back in and get it done you know the
first time it was with the cadaver
mm-hmm and then the cadaver tissue
didn't take but it I know that too like
almost a year later and then it slipped
out just training normally [ __ ] yeah so
AC ELLs are brutal oh my gosh she was
this it's the worst man it's the worst
and I admire guys who can come back and
look phenomenal and and and do it you
know still because when you mess up your
knee you know for me it just kind of
mentally just it messed me up a bit how
much physical rehab did you have to do
for that man I did a lot I did years
worth of it just you know the first time
I I didn't do it as well as I could have
because I'm like I you know I bought
pretty easy and I did like I felt like I
was bouncing back pretty easy but when
it went the second time then it was
harder because not only was I healing
from the ACL but then my knee was
healing in general just from you know
the previous surgery and then plus this
surgery and then I had something
different because in the first surgery
it wasn't it wasn't too invasive because
I wasn't using my own my own tissue that
cadaver one is nice it's right easy it's
easy if it works if your body takes it
how long did it take for it blew out
again man I was almost a year I was
training for another fight thinking I
could get back in shape and fight again
and then when I was training for that
fight it blew out again hmm
yeah I'll schedule the fight gussets in
and then AJ end up taking that fight
instead
mmm but it was um it was it was one that
that just you know it was like first of
all when I was out for two years healing
from injury you know I got to see what
it was like to when all the cameras
stopped flashing when people stopped
caring to get your pictures when you
know that whole feeling the whole
feeling that just that happens when you
admit that when you when you hit that
transitional point and stop becoming
that guy and it was difficult transition
at first because you know even though I
always told myself I'd never you know
put myself in the mindset of being just
that fighter sooner or later you become
just that fighter and that's what
happened to me so when I had to meaning
that you weren't the best well not not
just the best were an elite right yeah
just world-class
was an elite world-class fighter like I
used to be I was right on that level
anymore you know and that that was
something for me that was just like damn
you know your use of your legs was so
pivotal so it was so huge for you like
when that in that rampage fight I
remember that opening sequence when you
just darted after him blast him on the
right hand it was so fast like yeah he
didn't even know what the [ __ ] was
happening as soon as the bell rang you
were on him and he cracked him quick and
I was like that is some serious
explosion and that and that was even in
that fight
I could even wrestle like the last four
weeks of that fight because I had a I
pulled my hamstring in a fight so I was
just really just drilling up until that
fight of the last four weeks
so and when I came out like that I was
like I was a little insecure and I was
like you know what I'm just gonna see
what happened if I go and it worked I
was like okay I still got some spring
work perfect yeah so um yeah so so we're
not when I was into my career and just
kind of getting you know kind of trying
to figure out like what what's next for
me you know it was hard you know it was
just a hard place because you know I
really have anybody to talk to I didn't
really know what I was gonna do next in
my life you know and then when I started
to fighting again I still was in that
place where I just wasn't you know
totally back to fighting my mentality
because fighting is is something
mentally
it takes it takes a certain mentality
for you know and for me
fighting was something that I did to
exorcise some demons a bit you know but
having some time away from the sport it
allowed me to figure out other ways to
exercise so demon demons and you know
figure out some things around them you
know the things that made me mad at
things that were my fuel before I kind
of made peace with them and then making
peace with a lot of the things that I
was using for my fuel it just changed
the way I fought in the way I've seen
fighting so coming back to fight I just
wasn't that same fighter anymore hmm and
then when I got to the point where I was
like man I can't keep myself like I was
like man I'm not fighting the way I want
to fight and you know there's I mean
what's the point if I can't go and
compete the way I want to I'm only
torture myself so then I decided to
retire but then when I retired I'll
still was in a space where I was like
man is still something missing so then
when I did the five Meo DMT that kind of
put things in perspective you know in a
whole different way you know and it just
um it changed me it changed me a lot has
changed the way that you know I said the
way I think the way I eat everything
everything about it you know so it was a
it was soaked with Arctic and so many
since so many who since it'll worried
you know do you think that something
like that would be really beneficial for
fighters that are in the twilight of
their career I think I think it could be
I think I think every fighter gets to a
point where you fight enough then
fighting it kind of it kind of you kind
of get in a weird space about and you
know I've seen fighters go through that
period where they just kind of like
figuring out that why am I still doing
this you know they've had great moments
inside the cage but then they have those
down moments and those down moments are
the moments where it's harder to come
back from and I think those are the
times where you you know a psychedelic
or something like that could put things
in perspective and and allow the fighter
to see the why behind the reason they're
doing it and maybe create a new why you
know you're so different it's funny you
know I've noticed that about you over
the last few years of just I don't
to see you that often and when I get to
see you over the last few years like wow
something has changed in Rashad like
you're you're more I mean I hate to use
the word spiritual but you seem like a
more spiritual more peaceful guy I had
noticed that so that's why I was really
interested to have this conversation see
what your journey was yeah it's been
it's been one hell of a journey man you
know
[Applause]